the virtual high street was created to
support
local businesses impacted by the
coronavirus pandemic
working in partnership with sudbury town
council baber district council wanted to
create a platform for businesses to come
together
and provide a space for customers to
find their favorite stores on one
digital platform
many businesses didn't have a digital
presence and the easy to use platform
meant they could upload products
and information quickly and easily
the virtual high street provides a door
into sudbury's high street
connecting retailers with existing and
new customers
it also allows businesses to upload
information about their store opening
click and collect or delivery options
product ranges
and more the virtual high street is part
of our wider ambition to support our
local high streets
and encourage people to shop local
the platform was built by a local
software developer who is based in one
of the region's growing tech hubs
innovation labs in stowe market
the virtual high street is just such an
amazing tool to find out
what sudbury has to offer from pubs and
cafes and restaurants to the library
you know if you're not one for internet
shopping then it's perfect just to see
what we've got and then maybe take a
trip
out and enjoy welcome to sudbury's
virtual high street
so i'm sarah and i'm from ducking boots
and um
we operate a shop like this one um
with outlets lots of small businesses
and we also operate the two pop-up
shop units out the front helping
businesses to connect with local
customers
starting any business is a really tricky
um decision to make the further we went
into renovating our little shop
the more it was becoming clear that a
lockdown was going to be
inevitable
spring summer stock had just arrived so
the shop was full of spring
summer i was a bit concerned that you
know i might get stuck with a load of
stock
during lockdown we set up a website so
we could start loading
the product online helping local people
in sudbury to discover
and shop local providing convenience
choice and flexibility discover
fantastic local businesses on your
doorstep
i've been looking online for quite a
long time and then thinking oh i won't
be able to do that
so i'm sure if i we can do it anyone can
do it
my message to the locals that have
supported us through the lock down and i
suppose supported all of the businesses
through sudbury is just thank you so
much it's meant the world to us it's
meant
the difference between opening our doors
at the end of all of this and not
opening our doors
after the lockdown it was it was busy it
was lovely
the market's amazing and i think the
market saw a lot of people through
lockdown it's a really beautiful little
market town
the virtual high street project has been
a real success
over 115 businesses have signed up
over the last six months almost 5 000
unique visitors have used the site over
70 percent of businesses involved
had no web presence before the virtual
high street
our ambition has always been to expand
the virtual high street beyond sudbury
but we have been blown away by how
quickly businesses have adopted the
technology
and how many residents are embracing
this online access to their local shops
we've now secured additional funding so
we can grow the project
and add more functionality to the site
next we will expand to other towns
including
stone market hadley needham market and i
including a program to help business
owners improve their digital skills
so that they can get the most out of
their online shop
by expanding the virtual high street to
all our key towns
we hope to support the growth of the
local economy
we estimate that if just 15 of the adult
population in baber and mid suffolk
made a one-off purchase of five pounds
on the virtual high street
we could generate an additional 109
500 pounds for our traders the future
looks brighter for our local businesses